quedan abiertas diplomáticamente de
hecho felipe tiene el embajador francés
en eeuu regresa la próxima semana y a
partir de su regreso se reunirá con
altos oficiales de la casa blanca y del
gobierno estadounidense para avanzar la
agenda diplomática entre los dos países
esta era la primera vez que un embajador
francés era llamado a consultas en esta
relación diplomática de los dos países
pero la casa blanca a través de su jefe
de prensa enfatizó que van a tener en
cuenta el error que van a consultar
públicamente y hacer estas consultas
públicas antes de tomar una decisión
parecida en el futuro recordemos que
fueron 30 minutos de esta llamada
telefónica en la que se habló mucho y
los periodistas todos tanto prensa
nacional como internacional estuvieron
muy interesados aquí en la casa blanca
sobre el tema de francia que parece ya
pasar la página entre los dos países y
uno de los temas al margen de la disputa
fue un mayor apoyo de washington a las
tropas del sahel en términos de que se
daría esa colaboración
harry fue en el al final del comunicado
oficial de la casa blanca que dice que
eeuu se compromete a reforzar su
actividad y su apoyo a francia de los
países de la unión europea en las
actividades de contra terrorismo en el
sahel se le preguntó al jefe de prensa
hoy aquí en la casa blanca sobre si es
obvio a significar más apoyo del que ya
hay por parte de eeuu y ella simplemente
aclaró que que no que simplemente se va
a seguir con el apoyo que ya eeuu está
brindando a francia la unión europea en
esa región en temas de contraterrorismo
pero que no va a haber un apoyo
extraordinario o adicional para estas
operaciones
antiterroristas